@@@@
@
>>S THIK WEEON "OKBONOS,TE"
R ESGUT IS HARD OLBLM,OO
OFPRESR SOOF HANUMITS IEATAL YE
GLENH ISATEW N YK ORUNERIVSI.TY@
@HEOI JNS US TOIS dCUSSIS H
RENTCE BKOO,@ "HOW TOEA RD DAN
WH"Y.■@@
PSSAR HD BL CAN
REYOU  TMBMEERST FIRIM TEOU Y
ER
EVEA RD?
O>>H,ES Y.
I N BSOR0 7RS YEA AGON IN  A
ALL
T
IN E OHELDTASRO BNX, A IND
HTTA
UGFYS MELO TD REA YIDSH
WHEN I WASBO AUT. 3
HEBRN WEWHE WASUT ABO 4.
D ANGLIS WHE IAS ABOUT 5.@
D @EA RSSIND CETANLYRO FMHE T
I
MEAS 3RS YEALD O
T, FINAC I AM A LNGE IFLO
DI>>
O YOHA S AVENYFSEEN O
TESTU AR RD SDIEANG YONGOU?
'V>>
IEPE SNTEA YRS TG NKHIIN
OUABT IN OND AFF.I
WAS T FHITHIF CLD,UC ME@H TH
UN
Y/THSTGE, .LAE ST
INHE R AATR PIL FAM
MYHEAT WR AASNTAR GMEOR WR,KE
MY
R OT MHEAOU H.WISEFE
HHEADEE BNORN IN@DE OHEA,SS S
T HE T.AZ NISION LG EED WIP
EBONODYN ELS IAMETH FYIL@EA RD.
OND D'T K INOW, DIDT
INTHK I WAS AHANGINORG
LOVED W ANDASOV LEDY B MY
INSI
BLND A MYTSAR PENBU, TSO
G THMEIN MINE W VYER
LO
SOININTHG LTE  MFE WT HAI
INTHK IS THE D@PEE PEASLEUR áTHA
LI RRY ODIEANGULY NLCOD
INAN
SOD  I@AN BEGO TD REA
THER bMUE STEOM SE GEN
FA IORNHI TS.
ENTULY I TRIEDO T TCERA
PRILEROTAIL FANAMYATLT UIMYELOF
AS ETUR EEAOPNEW JHISEA PNTSA
ANOCSTK LSTD ILAV HE TYAM FIL TR
DED ANINHE,ED WIN ■OO LKEHE TYWE
THE.
IBLRO PBAAY BAHR TOW.CK@>>
E F I WUW SAYON  IURYO
SIWHIOATN UE ERYOER WEHE
IEHAPPST READING, WHER WOULD
E?ATTH B
INEW HAVENRE WHEY M W@EIFND A  E
AS ARINAR LGE■@@ORSE CHAIR
E IA4'VOR WN OUT SOANY  TI
S  DTH ION'TWHNO KW  HEETR
H.FTTHE FHRT ORHE T @FI
DANLA C IOLEPS@@ MYUL BK INTO
LS
UA SWIY THRIX OEV SEN■@
OK ANDD R IEAHR TGHOU THEM
TH
WIRE GAT G
WHEST' TON LSTGEEOU Y'V
EV
A SERATND RD?EA>>
HAN@ I TT CIRHA?WH
AS IEN W@OU YERNG, OU CLD@IT S
ER SRFOMEE OMTI UYILNT M
WILD WOUAY, ISADS I B FOR■@
U, FOOR AAL WK@D RO AUNETH
OCHI WCH IS@HA WT SHES SAY K,BL
TH
YSE ESDA
TISOMESME W IHEN'MHT RIGGIN ABO
,OK- -RI WNGTI A BK,OOXC ETEP
RFOBVUSDS NEE@ ORNG BEI
MM TEDOR,IN DNE ITA SY IN NSU
HAATTH C OIRR I ME TOHEDI
NGNITAOO RM EBL@EC B ISEAU
N'T ARWR TO ITE WNHE I'M BY
SE
MY
OUETH H HSEAS00,00 BKS I
THARE EWO TAR LGEFF OTESIC A
LE
YA BHI WCHWEETENM  THESTMU
HA
VE0, 30E MOR AND AN
APINENTMT EW NWIOR YK   TH
HEAN
OTR0.5, 100
E OKBOSRE.IKO  TRE WBEHE
IO EIK TBE MHE WREYIF W IS
ORYEBOMODE, ELSHA PER OPSNE S
OF
Y MS,ONND AIK LEO TW  KNO
AT SOMODTH IYS EERHILE I  H
ARE
AD WNDTERI.
E  IVITITYSOL SITY
DON'EST NTWAO  TBEPL COMELY
NE
LO.LY
DUYOVE ERD REA NIOFIONCT
>> OH, IEA RDVE EGTHINND A
AI'
M RAES DPETE RDEEAR.
IF C IANIN FD AGTHNYIN EE,LS
E WMYIF ISEL LIKTOIN FD MERE
ADREINEA CGERLOX BOP T
EOR MNGNI.
FLOKBOS  IOWN ALL THE@E, TIM
TELISOCI ADND@ UITOLNSIC  AND
N E S AIPCRTSNDRO POF
CO,ES EINRYVETHG UERND THE
ON
YOFE  M JOKEAY SSHA TT IF SO
OFD Y  MOLIEND WHORE A
ERVEELIETH IRSN E@
MAUTIDNO FF EUR OERMPUTS@@
IF
,EE INDD,RT ALICIFIA  IN
ENLLTEIGDE SCEO  TLOVEPSTHA
TH
EOM C DTEPURSOEV DOPEL
ALRSPEONANIEITS D CREIVE
ABOFIEITS HE TIR O,NE OF O
CTEX
PEEEF BORIE D CO  TBEOM
BAEDRRIC B THECS EPI A
INLL.ENIGCERTIAICL@TE
THON IGH DEC E'TXP TTMHEO  T
BEERF O V HYHIGUA QTYLI
>> LOWHAONG OUVE YATEE BN
I TOTHE ARES A GDUAT
STT EN A TINHE OUMUTN0, 195SO
NT IEN BEE TREHEAL HF AURCE
VEI' B FEENMEL ULTIEA TONINCH
E
THTYAC FULIST  ATHOR F 46
AR
YEW,NO AND H IEAV DBLOUED
ASORFEROSSF OSHNG ELIN TH
Y.
N.DU GU.RAEATCH SLOOSE THE
3STLA 1.EA YRS
C H>>OW D YANOUO@OT BH?
H
IAVAE RE GL  DATEAOF
NGACTEHIY NE ERGAV IAS HAE
EA
GR ODET AL REANG AND
G ITWRIN.ERENGY
ISHEOTRWI'E M AYRE PTTIRED
DOL@ON M>>
OW HEN OFT DYOUO TTHO E
OOASCLSR
W ES TNYIMUO  DYOEACH A
ME
SE
>>RME IVTE O OSUTF A SIXT
LEA
I  TVEWO SINSUS,AR ULYAL
UNRADUE,HO TUGOM SIMETES@ DE
TH
BO UADERNDGR
AEASAY TCHSDED WNEAY0 1:3
SESSBOEIV ATI GUTETNGO T A
OOASCLSR AORM E WHNYERSE O
ME,  UIALSULYW SHO UP AN HR@OU
AN HAALFEF BEOR THELASS AND TE
S TLLHESTUNTIN SCE IE HAT
TOITN IN A O BICFFEY MELF,
IHU SMYN  OESIC EEPXCT WN HEI
VE
HANDO  TFI AOO BK.
LUEITHR NDHNC AE' WLL H
FIRS HOU T.HERE
WT HADO YOU TNKHISHINGHI
WITHTH OEO PPLE?
L, WEL IAS NEV ALONENHE
WA
I  A CLD.
WEEER A FAMY ONSEF VE CR
IDEOWDO  ROO,ND A
THEY WER'TENAR LGEOO R.MS
MARRIEAS ID, W VYER@OL SITARY.@@
N'DOT
I DON'T INTH IS E FEAR O
MO
RTY.IT
BEI EVE FELIERCSY, A I SAY I
E
TH YOKBO'ROUEDI HOL,NG TT
ON
F E OAJETH MOREA RHYNSSO WE
DOD REAND A SULHOD RD IS
CA WENOANT@ POSSIOWY BLKN USBE
ENEOGHOU PE OKNOWHE T
Y OSC,ELOUGH@
T BUI PPSUOSEI  -- E@PPSUOS,TH
GH IAVN BEEERI MAROR
EARSAVND A HEWN KNO THE
LADYOR4I
E
TH CES BTPAOMNY TREHE  S, I I
OSU
PPE SOM IHIETNGMEN @ IS
UNPEAPASEDS AR. M E SIOLLTTSAY N
ONEF SHI PMSOE, SANTRGE
FRSPEON MOREUOO T QSTE AE' HS
NOFEON O MAV FIT WRIRSTE.
I
EPPSUOSIRY  MSPIT@S ISLW AAY
ME
SOW LKI FNGORET SOMNGHI.
BUT' THAHA BTNGEI AR EA RDE
BOIS
A.UT
ANSHA TT'HA WT IMMA PRILYRI.
AI'
M PF%NASSIOL T.CHEAER@@
M A PFESSNALARIT LERY
ITERA,  VY OSEAND. ONEI CR
ALWNO CLYS MF ELAT TESIM
IRTPALYNELF-PRN,ATECIOUT B
LYPA
RTPO S IUP WIT AER CFU
RY■@LO@ BNT BOMROSAUOSRU.
AUIN DOSR.I'
ER NVEEV LOWEDRN HO T T
STRI WTE EINRYVETHG@LL A
DANGLO WH ITA@LA BCK RLIOLNG
WR
CLD BOIPARATTH AN ERINGEENG
UD GTAVE ME AAS IF GTKAC  ATENST
OR CLLN I6 194IHE WN AS W A
FR
AHMESANSLW AAY ON■@ LG
LLLYEOWADALEG PS.@SO
A IMETOMHI OF A
DI
.SANOUR
EI'VESHABSTLI USI THE
BRLIAR
SEI NDRCES REAHSS ASTAISNT
I
IECRDHE WTHN EYTC SWIDHEM  FRO
CH
E AL CRDATMA SOGO NYEA YRS
O
AG AOM CTEPUR, B IAUECSE
T CA
N' ANDHALE@OMAN
ET SDOMNNGHI IE, MHO THUG@ --
RESTSISINEA LRNI
ONSTJU DT W'TAN DOO
WTRE AOU YTU SNTDES >
TELLG WUN
AN
AWHD AT S YREOUININEEG HE
UDENTS THAMIGHT T HAV  CH
DGE B OAUECSEFYB CE?SPERAC
I
>> THI TNKTHaHE TE YAL
UDOWTSEN N A,ND IE'VNO K
EM 4OR6EA Y ARSSDE STUS,NT  TH
NK THI@HE TREY'EL INTLLCTLEUA
ATSSTEA ADIF GTES AY  THEEREV L
WE
BUISERTHE FE D AIFNCREE.@
UTLAL BHE TER VY MTOSNT ISEENLY
E
LIMORYRA AM  TNGHEMPSILYE  HAV
RE
AD A LOTS, LESOT BONH IRHE
N
OWN DAN I.HOSCOL
FO TREHE@E  COME YTOALN, THA
Y,EA0 2 Y. ARSGO@@
AND @NK THIHA THAT SOM S  HIETNO
WIO TH■@ THECR SN.EE
I
,ANME A I R AAREMKTHT E
BE
G NNGIINOFHI TS BK,OO TUGHOH
I  TYO AIDVOT  IIN■HI TBOS OK@
S
MOSASH  PIFBLSIE NLY
OU MGHYENPP OONTS D'TEE SM
BNGUD JGIHEY B T R OIEEVWSF TO
ISOO BK@.
I N'HAVEEAT R BD,UT'V IE BN
ATO
LDUTBO.
T DOI N'O NTWA THEADRE TM.
E TH
ERWOEAR TNE EESMI OF
STTHN ENG EPESHLI-S INAKG
WORLD.■@
ON TND A INKHIT' IS
REVETILY, IN MORENEVHHO TUG
'SITER VYOY ANNNDG,IN A T@T HA
HAN BSEE THEUCES DTRONTI, THELU
DTINACTITRESUC OONER L@ITYAR
UD
STT S,IE A FASLETMROY M
CTRSPEPE
ANEPSIT RNTCELAMEY BHA WT IS
EDCALLRAUL CTULDI STU.ES
AEF  OTHRSNI UVE IIEITSNLIN
LLEG OTHF E
H-G&ENISNGEASPKIOR WLD, AND
YOEV
ERNEWS KNOT WHAT THA
ENENPHOM IONS.
EOW gRY WEAAS PHRTIPOE LICA
TNRRCOECMAS ESRESIN ACTER PFELY
HANNEGO OND A IS ASTI SLL
INOS AONLMTWHVE ERYEER
ICIN DOMESAT I SOU WLDAY
RAE MERORN THAF /5 3 OETH
NU
TE FDREESULACTIEN  ITH
ISEN
GLKISPH-EALD WNGOR
OWH@EAYLLO D áNTREEPSE A
TRSON OTHF E ICTELNTLELSUA I
OFINTHK YAET BRA OLF ETH
.ERCLKS
THBUT L WEYILS PAS AY.
TEITHRE IMISDYLR AEAOI GNGY. BH
AREEA ALRDY@- - R ONESOEAN
EYY WH ARETI GETNGERAS NTI@
VEANTH ES R IMPSILYAU BECSE
E EYTH'VHESTLO TIR CLEENLITE
UDEN FE LETH ONRY EVESI
T ADENDRES I@NIEC DLING
RON NTME ISEATWH UDBE TO LLEN
CAEUS D IHI'T , ANKTE YALAM
SICERANDIESOR F IE,TANSNC WH
HICS I THE ONETMEP DART ENAT
A
LEREHE@@EA RLDU ALT RION
SHA TENAKLA P,CE@WITH OERTH
EHO WLE YMAE ALRESIN@ A  OSLMT,
O
TUI QTE A C,ADITND AW K INO
E CABEUSEEVEI' BNUN AROD@HE T
HEOTRLA PCE. TOO@
CEINNLAIY CAME ARINTU S ESDI,
EVEYTH ND REREAMO ANY
THEV NEREA RDME ACARIN  LI
RERATETU
TH
'T DEYONNO KHO WT WAL
N ITWHMAORMI EIC DNSKIONR
EY
THTU SDYOND.SL IAN@
EY SHEDYTU T@ PSRLEEES
NNMA
DOA.
TUEYTH S MMOORNME THE.AR PKS
IS
ThHAS I W PTPLEOE DO IN @
LT
CUTUALUR S
THIL WLAS PS.
ESTHEEO PPLLAE, AS,IL WL
UWI
TH A FSORLE WHITL P,ARY
CA
BEE USOF SETHITNGHA I
TSE
EMBEO  AOI VCEEN  ITH
WI INEERSSN SG AKPEINT  AG
NSAIT.I
THN'DOHIKIN TSS JURT USSO
APYN O MAR PTS A IPP AACROH GR
MYH 70TTH BIR
AAS KHICND AIOAL MICUS  E IS
INITN,UTIO TND A ITNKHI I
BOUSHLDE AEDLIBOSHRY EVEE.WHERT
EAAS M TNTOCTRO PTERE FOF
HTHO TUGND ARE EXPFRIOSSN OM
SIIVUNERTYISDM AINNSATTRIO OR @U
PUARTWD NDICBL ATAOC SIE OLR
V
ENGRESONAL PESSSREUR
BU
ATT TH TSN I'T WHEAY IHAT SWO
H WKEORD SOS AO TE MP IOSA
ND O MSIASVERMON CFONYIT IAM
ICERANLE COLDS GEAN
UNIVSIESTI.AN
D,D,ND IEEY B■@OW NN  I
ARCOSENDSCHOSS  AWELL.
W
IIKLDOU L TETEE S I
HEOLABISD,HO TI
E HAV V LYERTLEOP HET  THAIT
WI BINE  MYET LIFVEE,IM EN
OU
TH ITHO.D ULGO@
BUHI TS IS@@ MORIN.
L  WITILSSPA.
MAS PASH WIT IT BNGEILD O,@
BUORETH MEAS MVESIGE DANSR I  OB
Y OUVISLREE THSC.@EN
D N SOTO MEH UCTHOO E-BK.I
EC RTLENYEN WTHROU MONY E
E-
OKBO EXPE.IEERNC■&
W E THNETYRKYO SLEONEC STI
ME@ A@ H-PLEEWTTKAACRDAND-LDHE@O
OUTMPERWHN IC G.MRESATND A
Y MPCOANWND HADO LADEOAD 0T 5H
RATELEHR TIL BRY TVE OATRRED
.
MRELIC MHACH CRI CNTOLEALD
IM
"T"INELE.
I TDUN IOT N AOOD
ENPEEXRIHE,CE WNERTH IER TMSF  O
ALE THQU WY ITOFTHA IAS W
INRE
ADHEORG  TLYHAST
UROCPRED ITHE ATAS W FNGLOOLWI
THDOT IN TTHK ATHEOO E-BK
GDE TNGO YSTRO THENT PRI ED
AOKBOSOS  MY FR.EA
T NTE INEERT, WCHHI I U
LEKNACOW AE DGISOMECN ONIC   AND
CO NCIERALTYESECSI, THE@
TE
INNDETRN AANYEEO PPLD%
WGRSAEEH IT OMENHI TS I
AERIERBLRAN DGEO  TFEE THLI
HEOF
TD. MINIT
A'SERIERBLAN DGE TROEA RL
INR.
A
BET'EUS IAS IN KOFD RE GAT
AY
GR.CE OAN
INCHHIVE EGTHRYINS ER MGETHWI
EV
ERLSNGHI EEND A IS
TRFFY ELDIFOULICT OUAR  Y
TRSPEONOAB ESTSH SNDARDS
OF
NGEA RDIR  OTOD  FINAIAGN
AT CLD BE CLEALD
INALECLLTUND AES AETTHIC
AN
STRDS  JUD IENGMTN
LA W TONOTHAS I ALEILVAAB
T.ON
ITH
NE ERISO GDAUINCTH
E ERIS IF I MAY UOR ASE WD
W NOSOUC MHPI DESD,SE@HE TRES I
IUALEELCTHO ALUTTYRI IN
LVEDN .IT
IT DSNOE'TEE SMO T ME AD GOOMO
ODEFEA TINCHG, EVE AS aN
STRUNT■@ E,VE AS T aLOO
ATRYVE NEUR D, EAEFTSHI T,
WH
TATINEACHHT OGUG.O  TBE
HS DOWOE A TCHEAERUG OHT A
ACALKELI YENOWT WHA OERTH TEE PL
AHEACRSCH TREEAG?IN
W OU YIN FD O?UT
E YDOOUO RVE GIR TTOHE
ASCL
O.>>
N
LE'M INV IEDIT TIT
LD WOUN b ANT I OSIRUONNTH
RIREI PCY.
OUTHGHHE TREY' pCTLYREE
TO
OMEOIN ME.
D PELE ARELW ASAYG,OM CIN
NOUTHGH NECLYSAESRIEO
OM YE, PEOE FMROOABRD
OR
D RO AUNETH CRYNT.
T DOI N'HORECA W.OM CES
T  GOUN AROEAA D GRDET AL.
NONL O OYOKBOOU TRST, BU■@
AL
SOEC LTURNGRI ONG DOI
SOMEEES  WA
T
NIRHE UIERSVEITHOS, THUG IHA
AND HWE AVNOET DMINESNC WTH
TEAK M OELYSFHE T RD OAIN
S
RMOF UTH OERITVENIRSS.IE
W
>>ADTHA M IETAD,Y THE
Y?
WA
PL C>>OUEAOFE YRS, AGOAN
REHEER WHIERTH T WSAS TWO E
OREAEEHR Y, ARSGO I@ID D A T
TYERIVSICH WHIAS HONETHRS   AY,N
LICATILRE COR.NECTSSIN
W THEK EEI SNTHE T,RE TON
HLYROUND A AAL HFHA TT I
D JOENYESWATHHE WN E■@@@
OLCO
NDRIZZEEA  PHOD MAN
AS@■@ TOOM CEEE S HERNDE
HA AUA MUTLAL TK.
U ENGOO LKIT AN ALD OIN-LE
VOR R NMANS.HO TMA
ANL WIILOL HMYD OS NE@ND A
VOOR FLBERGORE.
UNS MKEISIC RE, IO NOT
ORSU
PPTHT E@S.US BHEBU
TUULRAYLL I FND TTHA
SS
MIANIC RE I WEN I
ENREAGEM
F MNDY TEIMTORTA SNFD
EMEX
TRYELYTO SRMND A  DI
INRESTSS
GA ALI PUBURLEC CTE@HI WCH
NISHERO INTN CTDUIOLLCAED
W
HEAY WD REEAOW N."
ELOROGUTO THIS BOOK.
IT  SAID TNGHIS IN IT THAT
AREN'T SAID HERE,■@ WCH
ATFUINRIEDHE AIE>>
WHIK LE ?AT@
WL,AI I STHAT,OU YL'L
MRDPAONNGSAY YIHI TSOUND A Y  R
W
VIILSER WL PARNDO MY NGYI
TH I,D SAIT  THA YIFOUER W S
URTO
PAASCHE ES DK@BLA R TAE
OMPE C AARERNT■ ANDHE T LSEGFE
R ND AT IAS W NOTBL USA A I ITFO
ALE TABR  OAK, DESN IF IHA
BED ENEDRE CATY B@@ AER PSOA
ULRTPAICARETUL MTIICHNUP GRO
OR
A@ARCUTIRLAEX SOR
NTIEIOATN@R OF A@ PLATIARCU
ENI
GM OTITAONHAR W YVETEROU
WAALO T CLHE TSEHI TSNG -  -I
ILSTL@OL HD@ IWH "ATS@ TS HI
SENSNOEN@BO AUT BNGEITEHI.
AY."L CLALSE OURESLVIN PKO
MEAYER W ORYALF L TSHI
UF
ST
BUIDT SA TO IHEM, TFHEEG LS
E
LLFF, WOULDOU YOT N DANEMDA
RATEBE A INDTLD WOUOTN' D ANY
O
ODOLBEO  T TTHD ATSS HIWA@
D--
DIVIALDUIO NATESLINATI OR
HNUP GROS OR, YOUNO KW,HE TCET
OL ONGRAEF@OUT, I YOU WLD
STILO
UOU WLDDEM DANOU YR MEYON
BACK
EYHE WRE IAS WDEA hDEND A
STH
EY TRTTAEDBOO OE. MI
HIIDSA TUT ANKBOHA WT'M I
YI
SA
YONSHAIS TT YOUAB TLE
LLWEAD ME,OU YTNS IIST  THAURYO
SKDEIOUN FCT
IFOUBEER WE GINEL W I
RFORA BINTI ORAON@ND AOU YWE
D TREOLHA TT TIN BHERA
SURGN EEDHA B@ CSEHON  TONHE
OFSIBAS ESAI FRNTH OS,N EAS BIS
OF@VE UNIM,ALRSISEN  OTH@AS BISF
MULCULTM,ALURIS WOU YLDOU
RJU
MPFFHT OHE TRA OPENGTI
BLTAE>
MINHE SICEDWE.OOCHLS
O DOT N RUIEQREHE TSEUO QIN
TMEP DARTSENFMAAT MHECsTIOR
ARUC NLESI PHY
IT SWSR YOU PDFOROUNTE CONTMP
R
FOAN HUMTICESTU SDI AND FOR
TE
LI.TURARE
ATNK TOUHI DT ISOEOT N
ERMA
TT
AT H COUANNEAV A AELOLBSUTY ME
POCDIREFCEIE O YOR WK,OU
KNE WH, ERETH LSEGL FALFF O
AIN PM OR ALA PYR O AOV N.EL
OET
D NSOT MTEATRUO  TYOT
YOARLYON CUT AEBOHE TRINGI
IOFT.
ISSEAUDBO AUTF HAL THE
AUOCEEN T GET VYUR FUSIO TO
ST BUITOEE TE M'M INL OY
TEIN TTHG ETH.
EN THERE WAS APO SYMHEUMSI T
AYXTNE DN ICH WHIHE TACUL ME
ERS  ILU INCNGDI ONE
CORTEULSTRATULIMPORDTEN
BFR
OMYERLEO RGH MP, U
D USTATRE THE AND@N IS LTE
TO
HE TMSE ABUE M AND
RESRMIEPE.NTSE M
DANHE WN I CT MEAMYN, TUR I
ID'MET GNGTI ATL LITELD O,   ISA
'R
WEG GOE INE TTOAK FI
UT-MVEINAK BERE.
IITNVEHE TUD A TNCIEEOTA S@Y
NDE
HIUT BRY EVEDY OS THI
PLUSRMFO MECGOT  BSEAUE I'V AB
ESIVUSENI
OTLLWI NTOAL TK HE T
IIL WL EINERNTTASTUEIORO F
E
TH.RO GUP
TNT EE WIS VITASE LIKTH
EN, ATEVET  ATHSIREDE'SNT
TNNDIERLEAB.
ITNDOU I ANBS AYUTOLEL
TTEM
BAIMDLE TAN
UPID  SHASEPO TST IHE T PH
ENOMON IHA TT@ AOLS
CO IRITENGTHN EIE REV OWSF
ISNCK,OO I BDILUNGHOT
VI
RES IN THANT COU
CUAL@RI AMENCASP NEWERAP
ICH OW NF  O, URCOSEDAN
YSALWAEEAS H BN OURST EEDLIABSH
S
NE TPEPAR,HEYONE "W
ME
TI
EWE TH"NTIOR YK ASS"ME HOS LT
LIT OF SARTA SND F SDSOAR AS  AL
AI
C SEEOT BHNT IUALEELCT  LAN
ESD A.ETTHIC
IF I MAKE@ MEORESNE EMIMO ANG  H
ANEYTH CTNO- -HE TYNO CANT BWO
HAERS TY  TNHELREAR ADYEA.
THARE EW AE FEEO PPLHO WAN C
LT
ILNDADRE ANK THI A@TE WRI
WH
O C BEOUND I "NTHE
"METIS.
ET BUTHW  "NEIMRKYO T"ES
NEGAMAZIOWS I N IN
GUSTINBLISHAE"TRO FM HE
JOSO@ NS.EW"
ITS@ ETE BDY THE FMEORR
ORED
IT OF "ETHO SOJEW N"
TLDOUBHEESS IL WBEL HE TRE
R.REFOVE
CT BUIIMNOANT THINAGE AT  A
AD
REER OFNY A@ ICTELNTLELUA
REIN
TETS WSTHAVEOER■@,ND AN A
INLLIGEAT RHORDE SANDUL WT
TO
EA RTHD EW  "NEIMRKYO TMA
OZIGANESHOU WOTAN T RDEA
AT FSEASS B TORHEKOOWEV RIE NE
Y SSCEARBSATTH ADURNE " YOW RK
SMETIS" BDAUNYKOO RIEEVW,
IC I CTAERINLY@ILL NER
E WR
ITEVA RRW IEFO.GA AIn
LLI'AV H TG INInOWI DO THM. THE
Y
THAV HE BOMECE BADROLY
COTURULRA
WNL OYWOTH OE YEA
Ag ITHO ATEA RDNE OF OHE TIR
RICKRO CCSTIHO W I WLILOT N
MEIM H,AK M AGINY VER SIOERUSCO
ONARMPIS
WOT NEI BNG@@RO IIFCANIL
WHICHCO HE PLM EDARRI PENC■@ TO
H
EYEER ABSUTYELQU ETALIVEN
GDS IUAN IHA TTTAS WNL OY  IN
OUUR ABSDIOEA RCTRYNARAUL CTU L
PRS DTHSEISS T KATEPHE TM
OM
FREEIN THIS.
ATTHS E@NE "YORKIM
TH
TH IATS  WWAE E LEIV. NOW
THHES I TAY WE W RDEAOW N.T
OF TRSOUE,LSYHE ATCAO N'@  C
PARS
Y
THE'RMMNG URAALATIC
TH
EYSP MISL.EL
THEIS MUS WDSOR.
EY
THERE POUSTPO>>
CAHA WT HIEDUS T IS,N YOP
IOINN?
>>OR 33RS YEAANOW N, D I
DOSHT N'WIO  TBESE # WDHIT
MY
AT LE ANCUATAELA AN
OOBLNDM, A A IM NOT A
LITICAYLLINPE SAK NG,OTVE EN
UU
LTLYAL,■UT B FMRO7 196IL UNT
PRTH
E ENEST FOR/3 1F@ A
CEEY,UR WHAAV HE DHE TWU
LL TUMRIPHF TH
COTURCTEULTH IRETE UNI
ST I AESNDENTHN E RETI
ENEAH-ISSPORNGKI W T ALDND AOSO
LWHMEATSEESREN EXT TTTHO E
WEOFSTN  THE@TE WESRNND AHE T
O
W OEM TY REL EY IRNTELON
FO AIOATNND NOT ALL A UNPO @
ATWH I COU WLDLALEAORINRNG
WIS.
O
T GINO THA CENG ORAS PS.
DE, HHE WREAS TNOHIS T  EDIN
EP
SE BY W?
TWOUT  YO@EA, ARSGO THE OLDBR
MUISITH UMSE REANGDIM ROOAS WTR
SFAN IMEORDHAONT WST IOW N  CA
ED T BTI LSHRAIB.RY
IECEI A PALNEHO CL RO FM
E GANTLENEMHO W@@AS W THE H
MIINCOD  HNGEAS THI
WHOL TD MER OVEHE TG LONDI
PANSTCENEHO T@THT EYER W
AU
INNGRAGUTI NHE TIREW
ISENCIT WH AK- WEENGLO  CE
IOBRLEATEDCAN LL■@ "ANFGE A O@
O
INN.ATRMIO
I SA, AHY W YREOULI CI
S,WED LLE W ONL■ WTAN YOU
E TH
ERER FOTHDAAS LT YRIDA
TETEAFR TIA MEHE WYON UND A TWO
GEHEOTR N LENTMEAVLLWI HAE  PA
ISLNE DIOCUSSNN O WT HAIT
AN
MES CLLTUULRAAVTOY  HE
ENED RETHFGE A OMANF IORON.
I SUD AIYO DON W'TTANE. MHE
D SAIH, O. YES
ERBEIL WL  SIR SO AND SO.
SON ID DW  K'TNOHEOWH TY
ARHE
ATOT G RRHEFF OANDEEND
AIEX
PLODNE T ME ATHEHURT
NEIRATTH S AO SND SO WAS@
ETHNCEADI BTIRISHTYHOUTRI
ON
MANF IORONTI RALRIETEV
I ID IID DOT NNO KWHA WTT I
NDSWA A IID DOTTOIS WH IN F
I  I WIDHOSHE TER OTH GE
N?LENTMA
D SHEAI OE  HISEANGDI
ORAU
THY ITONOF SARTWE.I
'VIDSA IER NEEVEDEA LRN TO
NI'M AOTT AUR sEHA WT
WASO
FTRES. I
HEDAIOU YHT OUGO TOM C YE,OU
.
SAHI TSSID RS.ULICOU
SAI ID'R YOUE TOI GNGOSK A ME AU
Y ORITONHIOM SETLENGALD
INNATRMIOEVET RRI A AALNDN
TH
ONITORY AROF STWEND A, I
ET
WREDCH@REURE, AMSEUP SPO
R
TONTREEPSEOOHE T BK?
M HHLY IATDENAQU TEO
ENPRREESTHT EK. BOO
YB
ANOUYOD W
D L WIL NE. COM
OD
GOSIYE-B, R.
ATT BUTHS IHE T BTISH
BRY.
E LIBRY O CGRES WREHE I
ELIBEEV I TPE SAKAYOD@@TH IN E
F
MUD@ RM HAS G NOTEON QUITE
ATTH
LAT ISTEAE HOP N.OT
I'THT ATUC MH INASHITONGNTH
EES
T THERACKANS D INSTRAS
WHE  HHAVDELY WND OEDUR IC
IV ATISIESLE CNDOLSGE@ AND
IC IAV HE,NK THIRODE, STDYE  H
FOR URLTALUR PSEPOS ARE GAT
INUTITN LIKTHE E OREW"N Y K
S"TI
ME IHI TNK TYHETEPE ORA N
INAT GHERECUB PLIRA LESRI T
N BVEEEINPE SAK AT G AATRE@
LINYUBC LIBESRARICR AOS  TH
NT CEOUD, RYAN@ ISK AHE TM
TOUABTIR RE OK CO
ONECLLTI
I ASTHEMHE WER THERE A
MAGINTAIN TVEMSHEELSS A
RCULIBN LRAANRIS.AN
THD EY DTEHEISARBY MNE @
TELLG
H
EKLLND A A TOOFT OHEEN TY
TE M TEHATHE TYOW
COETRENATENPO UN RELYN UPO
PR
OVCOINIDG  SUTMPERS.VIERCE
AK BITRET WSHA LS ITEF OY  M
HEUSBET CAE IOU WLD HEAVEE B R
E WHERS  TINHIITFELI W
ETHIO VARUSRA BHESF  OE NEW
RK
YOCUB PLIIBRAHE WN IAS W
I STAEDRTNGEA RET  ATH
ME
LRBRAN OTHF E BNX
PURA LICIBN WRYHE IAS WTI S
LL SSOMA IOU C CN'LDTARRYHE T
OK
BOSE. HOM
EE TMYHRRSIS STEINDLYRI CARED
THE.OR F M
D  WENT FEM ROTH MROELSE
ANFTER RDEAHR TGHOU  IT
TO@OR FDAS HAM H B ANCRAHND
I
HAEDUS TTP. U
IDES D ANDCEEDT@ 15HILU CNCNG Y
NKEICLSMY IN AN HDHEOR F T@
BW
SUTH TAYO ER%2N 4D ING
.RO
OM
I  ASNE CORLLGRND UERUAADTE
NGHA
VION ALO FEL AHIWSPND
FOENSPD EARSRYGININO TEA RD
ATT OUTHIB LRYRA.
ANHEOR F TAS LT 4RS YEA HEAV
ENBEIN TRY TGO RDEA T OUTHE
LERARY WCHHI NO HAN
ONVEI' D IWHE AT.OU CLD
IBU
TTESOR WRIE M DPLEEY W
ISNIAP HPE TNGO OUR PLIUBC  LI
S.ARBRIE
TOUR ORA LIBRYTE SYS IN
GENEL.
SEEYTH URE TDO  MIVCEEH MO@
E M--OR GENEROVNMUNT FNGDIHA T N
Y
D I@ DOOT NEA HRE NY AONINEI
ARERTH PTYNGUN RNIOR OFFEIC
TTH
ISEIM TKIALNG AUTBOUB PC
IEBRLIARSEP EXCTOT @TT U,ER MEO
DTE BETROM C.TEPURS
ETEOM CPUPER RHI C
G Y>>OUAC BK TO WUT HAYO
IFIDSA, ONOU Y DD  M'TINATYA
D, LEANOU YTIPOR LICS■@S ER VSU
H
E OERTHSSRO PFEHAS,OR WT
UL
WO SYOD UOU,AY Y KWNO ->>
D IHI'TON TNK- -VEOR F ME
RFOER INTPTRUIN, YGON I D
IN
THS IKT'IT P AOLALIC
ONESQUTII'
IRM TED OF BEG. TED■@■@
VENIN VOTORG FOC DEMTSRA  '
RERFO P ODESINTR F SSTIAOCLI
EN
WHLD C IOU TIN FDRM HEFO,
ST'LES, ITAEDRTHEN W IAS
.
18@HE
E IRE'VN BEE VINOTGOR F 52
YEANS D IE'V NERED VOT FOR  AR
RA
CAUBEPLI DFON ROGCH CAT,
D N'OU WLD STRTTA. NOW
FOLLEIV A THE RCAUBEPLI NS
THE T,RE OLER T TMHEGI FORVE
.
ME
I'TNO A■@@ CATSEONRVE.IV
YTM I'ANUTNGHI B A  CO
TIERNSVA
K THI INHEATTH TD NI UTE  ATSTES
E
S ENTLM AOS DEDTRESOYY B
AMHE
CINE TO O TICFFE,THA CH
,MIARNGNGMI SLIEL FW,LOND A
A
HE UURSSEDS W@ELD COU AEM
TECIANPAUR OEL SSSSHFINE A,TH
WH IATS  WEE HAV PEDCEROED
O DTOOAT AN NNAIOLEL LEV.
D I INK WEE HAV DETE
TIBRRLENGHISO T THEOO PRRE
OP
PE T ILENSHIRYOU CNT.
LI.MR C WONNT,M HOIOT V FEDORTW
VEE ICNESSHERTLEDIG SNEHE
ARWE
LF ABIE LL PNDUTE FIV
N LLMIIOHIREMO C URELDNHEERND TO
LVEYE.IN
LE BITE S IDAINISEN DEFSETH
IATRAT GHEE D HASEON
HIEREVYT C HNgELDOU TOAR PYTLMA
FO UK#P R THI YS,OU KW,NO  S@ A
T
BEE H CLDOU.
ILT BUST IM A NOTAP HPYIT WHI
M.
NOT DOI N'THINTHK ISS I@ A
LI
PODICATIL CEERFFEN
I ENT N'EV THI TNKSSHI I   A
CUURLTALFE DIFNCREEEC BSEAU  IDO
THT INETHK EREAN C B
URCU
LT DIFRENC T IESNSE
E.NS
IT@ AN ICTELNTLELUAFE DIFNCREEAN
D AN AICTHESETFE DIF
AN IOUTHGH TAT HEOSE U T
BENIS MCO TED, IT@IM ULTELATY
A
S E  BAPI STURIAL
ENFFDIER.CE
YTHEIERIE BOUELT TVEHA R DIEANG
D
ANINEA TCH T AGNDGNKHIINUT ABO
H
EHATES THAT SEE BGHTHN OUT
ANRI WENTT AND@AI SD@AT@ MRSTE
OROO GD OU Y DNOO T.@ GAT  EALOF
OSDAN MT OFSE THEEO PEPL I NOWTH
UENISITIE ANDTA CERLYIN
THLEPEE OPEN  ITHED MIAND A
NEETH " TYOW RK DESIM"@'TON
E LIBEEVATTHL.T  AALEI
ER Y BVEELIET, THA YKN
,OWHA WTAS H I GOTO T@@ DO
WI
THICOL PITLE
TSOgRO WKYAS W@ ARE GAT
THGHURDEUS BUM HANNGEI  OU
BUAT GARE@RI WER,TE HRO WTE A
K
BODAL CLERALI "TERETU@ND A
ECTECI BNSEAU IT IE HDDSSREES
MS
HIFELO THEVOLIORRYNA OMA
ISRXTRI WRTE ANDE HAI STAD KEDA
RE NTFOOU YR TK.TBEXOOAN
SHED  I QTEHT RIG.
DEHA, WVETEROU YRIT POLSIC
E,ARHA WVETERR YOU AIOIRSPATNS@
T
TEOKBO,E TAKSPHA SKEREEA OR
HOORR @EE INDBITHD E EBLOT N E
AS FNTDAUNME RISALTSTDEA IUT B
ASE WHT OUGO TEA RD IT.TA
EE IKENDTHD ET BES TST HAHA BE
EN WENRITTOR FOU YROOEX TTB
D
AN ECADUTE YRSOUFEL FMT. I
NBEI GI BHI TSKOO BNGSAY YI
FO
INN ATRMIOISLYEA RDI
BLAIAVLA TEO@S. U@
WHLSHE ALMIS WDOE B FNDOU?
ANETHWE ANSR,T@ ISO  TBEFOD
ERD UNWHIS IET LW ASO BE
FO T ID,NHEAT GRETES MDSIN
THAN
D  GATTES W@RITE
ANEY ARE U TALSULYHEAM SE
TAM SE,OU YNO KW.
ITBE TSO ND FOUN I I
AKANARPEE ONMID LT.IT
O S I TBEOU FND INLI WILAM
I
ITBE TSO  IOU FNDN@ DAN.IT
T ISBEO OU FND@SE IN   ANRVTYA
.CE
LD WIOUTN'IN MD@CA SO-EDLL
MUTUICUL BLIRASMOREFIFE ,
Y,SA FOR@IS HNIPACPO PUREYS SETE
RERE TO ACPLESPHA SKEREEA
YENEV B CESVAERNTI,  WLDOUAY S
NEFI.
HEE THOTRNGRI WTI@SF O CVANTESAL
CH TSOOUHE TSIm LITF  OMAHUN
TS
ARND AMAF  OHU@N T.UGHOHT
W YIFOUHIS,IS HNIPAC
MURAULICTULESMLI,  RTHT EMDEA■@
RVCE
BUTLEM THEOT ND REA BAD@ WR
L%
M TTHE ROT NDEA I-TLLUGHOHT
MAMPS ERSIAU BLYECSE THEARY E@
N ITWRTEBYON CARMPTEORYBE MEMRSF
TI P AARLACUR, AS WEAL CL IT, ET
TOKANIHE TDY STU■F  O
TUTELIRARE,EE INDD, THE SDY
T AOFLLS  AHERTAS WEE HAVOW N
N NEDO INIETH UIERSVEIT ASND
E
TH@LE COLS, I F.AL
ITTL ILNOAKSE U AETTE  CO
IT
MIL WLEAKS U AOR WSE
UNCO
WAL FLINLY BZEKAALNIS US A
TIA
NA.
ANWE HAVENO EUGHRO TUBLE
THT TH.
>> WRI AOT L AUTBO@ CMAORC
CA
MCCO
RAEMNTPO
. Y>>ES
ONNOKBO IAR PR,CUTILA A VYER
EA
GR ABOT OKND I'MER VY GYO
NG BURIT IP. U
K BAOOLE CALD "OODER M"IAIDN.WH
H ICEWRI IT IBO AUTNHI TS BO
.
NYFTHCC MARSY'EL NOV ASRERE
LERKMAAB,@DINC ILU ANGLL "@LAL
THETTYSE HOR
I INT N'THTHK EDEC SON O
IR
THUM VDOLESRETE QUIS
NEFI.
FMESO OIS HLI EARER@@@SOVEL■@@RT
LILKAEM RAROOEBL B.KS@@
T
BU HHEAS WTTRIEN   ONE
MAEPIEREC,CH WHI I SOU WLD
IS -- IEA MN, OFON CARMPTEOR
AMANICONIC FTI, OFIC FONTI@  R
TER
IT BNYUM HAN BNGS SLLTI
AL AANE DNGMOS, I WLDOU■@LI
ST PLIP THRO'S@, @DWOI UL
LION DEL DLOIL'SND AIS H  ST
RENTND ANI MAGCEFINTMA "NSOAN
BUIFT  I HAD TO@FOOT VE ONR E
VEIV ABY LGINCAME ARI IN,T
UL
WOBED BL "D MN,IDERIA"WH
AICISEA FOMRSETO SRYND ATE
PRRLEERAAIBLCH WHI I HI TNK
S @EE DP, I@TLIMPCIAR WNGNI  HA
RRR FOCUMETEN ACAN S.IEOCTY
I OEA MN,UR■@RAUN G-C CRYNT WH
ARE ERCHONES HNTO AEAPPRS
ENONSLESY ISEL TEVNIO AND@
AMES ME.@
HELYNG ARIS SAY PNTSIREDE
N,INCLTO WHYUO  DYOOFAL TK @ 22H
SDRILENRET HOHE TR OREHE@@ AND
DUYOAL'TON TBO AUTHE  EN TS,
PEH
E  HAPRHSSDRUNEDF O
NSLLMIIOOLF O DHARSLA TTHT E
IR.N.A. SSGNDPEIN@O  TEUCEDAT
ND
HAS? GLEUN
ITAN CNOIE BELVE TAD MSSNEF O
AT
WH H A IM.RIEANG
IT BUITLLS AAI STRTGHUT OF O
"BODER MIAIDN"AU BECTSE I IS
ETHATLT UIME W.TEESRNIT
S H ACATOISRIYLLLO CLYSE
BADNTCC AOU OF A TINRIERFYG@
PIC
ALED ENGXPORIOITN DNIGAZE
EXBY
MANIC AND TANEX
ITTHAUORS IEIN@ 1509-8418 TSI
LYMPE WIPLLUT O A OTHF E  SO
TEHWUTES NRNIVATERI AME NSCA
RDIN
OCL TERO REA THEAYO  T
E
THIELDGO FS.LD
ANHE TLA BON GG,AN AN@
EXTRRDGRA
STLIFIBUAVSER HWIE THHE TASM
RA
R
IGINENGIF MANONTAESTI, A
ME
ILCADILVANLI, A@ HAN MY
SCS HO W IAT VAS ALBO
ALLFEOWDROS UNS A IM AUT B
VEALOTFO TLND A AASLL LA
S UANGGELD ANALNO KEDWLSGE
OD ANWHAC PRES ELYLENDSS OTH
OL TEHEFYOG O VLENC@ AEND
NDRWA AHO W IS SLILLTI AVE A
DAINANG DID FINDLGND A@
PRG IMLAINE ATTH HLLWI  EV NER
D
ANDND IEESE  HHAEV NERD. DIE
SHE
INSES RPOORLEIBHOHO
LERRIBOS PSSEE WE HAV  OUT
THERII
IHES■@ RIBPOESNS FLEORHO TSE
PE B WLEHOPWLE U F THEEREDAL  P
ILBU
HEESS I RLENSPOIB T FORHESE@ MA
WOPPELEAK BHORENT IO@LsCH SOO N
T SHD OOENILCHDR.
ERISE - - WERE A A CRYNT
THATASAD H A KINDF O
PEUAETLNGNG OOIIOEL RIGUS
VIVA SHECEIN TEA YR 180AND SI
EOLTMUANLYUSE WAV HEEE BN
MPCOL
OUED'S GOOATRE BISK   A WT  MC
HTIAN MY SMEYOAV HE UD REA "B
ODLOID MER
>> OH, IEA TCH ITAD STEOY,IL S
MUAV HE@EA RD IYT BOW N
INCSIE REAERD EINRYVETH IG RE
ARLYAL C, FEOR 2 3OR0 0
TI
PR HLYAB IEAV ITEM MIZOREDY B
TT' ISCI FAS TTINANGTH MOE
YOKAS TT,HA,RI BANAU BECSE
E OT RSTW TIM TESTHA IEA RD
,  NOU CLDOTEA RD IT.
ADAN IITDM TS TMYO @ST
.ENUDTS
I E DO -- D INO'TON K
AFR15R  O0ES PAGHEIR FST  TI
TED ANAFR70R  O0 8AG PESHE T
COSENDSEEC BAU THEHE SER
NSIN
TEYELTY SISZELID
HEVENERTSSLE OVEINHERWLMG.
'S
ITINHO SCKG.
OR'SIT HG.FYRIIN
AN IT TAKES AER VYGTR SON
ACST
OM
T REOU Y BOU TAKHRT, I@ IF
REYO
U R  YADOUYWAO INT THE  CO
F OSSM OOKE THBO TNHE YOURE A
EDWARERDYO
AGEU TNXT ENAORRADIRY
ND
LA
YOGET AN@■@XT ENAORRADIRY  VI
Y ONSIARITTEINNSOF
ALRSPEONDY ITAN CERRAHACT.
ETUYO G GATIS VN,IO A
ENIGFRHTG IN OSIVIONFHA WT IS
DEINED@■ SNGETOMHIY  VEREPDELY M
IDDBEEDTHN E AMECAN@
, IRSPIT TINHERI AMEN PCHE.
HEDAN TOR ME YOUEA R TDHEOO BI
IN FD THEOR MYOE U WL ILBE
LE REA THE BK.
ITS@ -- I AST'SSE CLOI
INBE TO EG INTHME ACARIN@
PROSE EPI MOR@@E P EHAERPSNVETH
AN FAUNER.
OUND ILIDIVUAOO BKSY B
FAKNULE LERIKAS " IAY LNG DYI"
E
HAOR MEGI ORI,LINATYUT B I
THD WOK ULAVUYO H TE@OO GAC BKTO
MO "BY DK"IC@ORN AME ANRICA
TICHALY FTUL CSPAOMRE TO"B
ODLO MN.IDERIA
WUN HEYO DEA RDMAYOO U KE
TE
NO
N>>O.
AT, NOTH TOO,AS W IEDNHITI
E HAV A SCAS ALNDOU.MOMERY
R
IREMEMBE IHA WTEA RD.@
INDE,F I@
FAI LLNEOV WHIT IT,HE T@ I@
EMMP REMBEITR .
LDD ANHOON O T ITEROR FEV
IN
INEDDE, HI TSK  BOOURGEME
TIRIMOZA
MUSTE ASETH L PROSSFEORF O
TUTELIRATH IREN ED NI UTEATSTES
OWH ONAASCCIOLLL WILAY S TO A
OORYVE GDLA C, FEX NTEE WK,RE
AD TN'NYENSOS "S.YSULSE"RE
O IADTD LUTOUHE WNEOU Y'R@
ON
AL YWIE THROU Y
ADTGA A AINNDGA AIN
D BR
OOT  WONNS MITEA.
SSITS Y BEM MYORND AE COM
, AINNDOU Y KSW,NO ATA WE LK@
ITOUABT EO  TONNO AERTH, LET US
E
CI OT  ITONEERNO ATH.AN
DND IEEHTON TIGT  AETH
TERE
CI@ TN'NYENSO ""SEYSS,
D
ANALTO TUT AKBOT. I
TRTPALY WREO AD HT HAIEAV T
Y
SA IBO AUTT ITHE@OO BK.
MOENNGZI W O OTUTFAS FONHI
INNRIMECADU ETICAONAU BECSE  A
H
ITN BADEERU BD LITAZEDAN
BAD INTOUS J RIOUTEPATBYN  EDE
T ITINTHK S I NOT OYNL A  LE
TETIGIMAUT B A CCIRUAL M
OFEACHG DAY ALWHAS S BNEE
A THEAT GRE@EL RIOIGUS
ITTR
ADNSIO.
THAND REE GATUL SECAR
ITTRADFNSII
A
RNG A
LD WIOUO GVE EEIT LTL
RT
FU
YO TNNCAOTNKHI, YOUAN CT NOBEAC
UTE W MHOITUTOREMY.RE
INMBMEERISG  AELOLBSUT
NTES
SEL IATO THIING.■@@
YD ANIFOU'T DON RDEA ANDEA RD
AEPDELYYO INDF UON D'T
SSTH WS,HEER YOUEM MIZORE PO
IT OR,  NOT D YIFOU'TON
WENDLYUL APOPLEEY ESSSSVEFPO
ON SRYTRORG WKSF LURERITATE
TAN
DUGHO IEENDD,YOHE TN
LLWIMP IH EROVISHIURYO TINNKG,
D ANIF W@ERMP IOV OHIS
INIT INGF  BECES ANY MR.  TH
T AD
ULTEN TDHAT HAEA ALR DY
TT  LASIRTHDEF  OTH
CEHEY,UR TOUIN  WLD FREAOR
SATWH IFT A AERT MLLOSOURE PCIS
U
ABS TTHIRYOU CNT.
WEEN DEFVIIND DIALDUS,IG RHTS  A
ETHT EC RENF TEVO OETHPE SAK
SH
OW WEE CARSI PASY ATONEL
OUABTHE TM.
TUNSCOTION.@
T DWOI ULEA FRHEOR F T
INHI TS LGEAR AAR VDIE
ADEEIN DY ANGOL HDIN O O SP
HATO
W WTEEA R
WIF SETOP R TDIEANGT BES
HTHAE
USCAE TN HII TNKE WL  WIL
TNKHICL AS RLEAY OR AS@  WENO
D, LLANWI WE  BLLEUB SJECT TO
MAERY.
FIINITD  PLLEROWFUY OFFSIVE
AT
F NE O OETHWO TAJ MOR
ES CTIENALTEDIANDAS   IDPR
PEES APTHEA LSTIS DSHNGTIUIED
AD
GRF TEUA OETHENT EIRRYIS HTO
OF UEALITVENIRSY,ND AE I'V   Y
UGHE T FREORRS Y6EA,
IOUTHGHEV NERHO THIHTUG TS
NTN.MABU
T HE S B TSTOAEDTHO E
TSS PHERE THATDE  HHA@EV NER
E
ADOO A BK T SOUHRGHECEIN H
FTLEAL YE.
OF IRSOUE,VEEL BIEIM H.
AN SIEEUM COLNSSER  OI @ER VY
SBIDUOU HANTOISRILIS KER. M
LCHMIAE@ES BLOSHSS PMICLROAI
THT'TOE DSNRAT MTEHE WERTH  AT
ENESPRIDD  RTSEA. NOROT
NK TIHIT IAT MTE GATRE
AL
DEIF
AnOU Y WEETOT  SN ANS INCE
MEOF
ACARIN@ULTULND A
E E TSTIMADE W H AHE FATR
SD ANAEON BRE PSDESINTEF  OTH
sITUNEDITTETAS O AS W NSSLE
H
ANNOHDA A AMSNDOH JNYUI QNC
AMADS.
DANE  I'VHEADRE TMOT BH AT  LE
IT INCDING@HE TIR
ERLE
TT
EYN E ERMEOF@NO EOURMS@
ECTEINLL ATND HANUME CULRE.OB
Y,OUVISLHE THE FATSOR-N
MBWHIOATN  WOMEAY M■@L  WELO
OMA
KET NUREXATD R HEANNSO
PRALENIDTIUO D@ ARE AON LFR
OMOH JNDA@ A AMSNDOH JN QNCUIYAD
TH
, ATIHI T,NK@ ISOT NAT MRTE
FF STOCOBO AUTRER UTT
THHAKIN T ITS ARI TEREBLIN
OANSTCEUL CRATU LND A
IHIOM SETT  TNGHAWE■@IL WL
Y
PAOLOR F PALITICLY
INLYITAB F ANDALINLY WHO  KN
HOOWS AT GWRE T PRI WL IL
R Y>>OUTMMEN,BO AUTOUID D Y
Y,IC MELHA BSSSHESLO Y D,ID OUSA
Y
SA AIO DUBUSIS H?RITOAN
IIMDIN H AER VYISUB DEYS >
ORHI
STIAN.@
SIAW A PCEIE BYIM HN  IATTH
ET
WREDCHRKNEYO TINESIM"
WH
E HICIDSA WHYDHO SUL WE
FKEMA ASUS AHEUTBO WERTH
T ACUAR PTIRDERE PSIRNT O@
ENESPRIDANALTI CDADITEONAS H D
AN
YEE DNGEA RDI ATLL A?
HE
AI SDT' IS@OT N AT ALL
IASEESNTAFOL R RE P.DESINT
IGEYTH M BHTEH MUCRET BTE PR
TSIDESENOTOR F NGAV HINEA RDAT
FHADIN TSTIS DGU
HA WT DMEYOO U  BANY  TI
ERSEMERV?
>>VI SERNGHEIM TE,MM TRIGINYO
LTALUR WD.IN WHHE T
YIHA WTIL WL PASE E
>>
UO  DYOIN FD YFRSOUEL
EDOLATT YA?>>
T a YE?AL
>>
WEA YH,HIT TSEHE- -
>>NO MNSETOM CPLY.ELIB
AM@VE ORW BLMHEED SYTUS.NT
>>
'M NNGAL TKIUT ABOST
.ENUDTS@
OFPR
>>I
VEHA- -'M IOT NN I A
DE
MEPARTNT.
IOR DIVED CETHLEYA ELINGSH
DEPA.
DAN TT'HASTLM AOS A QRTUAERF O
YNTCEURGO AAUECSE IID DOT N
KE
LIWAHA WT S HPENI.NG
ISOOT GPPEAOIEDNT@Y  BETH
YAPO COR ATIRAONS A UN
TYERIVSISSRO PFE T,ORUGHOH I
HE
ACER FOTHSHNG ELI DE
NTRTPAMEEAI,  T O FCHORERTH DE
NTRTPAME
ANCH TIEAAT G AREAN MY
EN
UD
BU
NO,O, AHE TRERE MYAN
OPLET  AYA,H BOT IN MY  PE
RAGE
NDONTI AEROU YNGHA TN
SEARWH, O EIO SERUS
RSHOSCLA,SI PASATONEEA TERCH
O
WHINAR CE YNSTEELBO AUT
OmANT DS  ARTDAN aUTBO THE  PR
NGERESVIANF  OSTOFRDDAS @
UC
EDIOATN.
NO I DON'T FEELLA ISOD TE  AT
LE
YA.DO
L F IEE IDLASOTEN  IA?ERAMIC
IAHYE, UE GSS IN A WO. I D
ITS OEOEMSE T@E, M'M I ASO D
WHMEAT@OKUT OSPLDEN O M.STONER
U
YO WOWKN,? NHYOT
MATYGE A,HA WT C TOYHE D TME
?
ON TNTWASL  TOELRUETH T.TH
ULEADRDFAYOW NADSTU CULLLRAY
NGEASPKIND AEL INTLLCTLEUASP
NGEAKII
SEUP SPO IL FEERL FAIYIS
ATOLED.
IEA'TON RDEV R OWSIEMEF   BE
IUSCAENO KWHA WTHT EYIL
LE.TH
L  WEYILBERI WEN BEOEPL  @
O FE PFOROUNDES RTTMENEN OF
ME
.
MAN'ES■ERTT.@
ATIS
OLED.
BUOU Y KW,NO IAN C'T FLEE
IS
.ATOLED
OOMI' TED TIR@EA RLLTOY O  GON
H
E MU AADS  I ACHS D ION
PPOFT  AOOEW N BKHA TT IE'V
TEWR
ITN.BU
EVWHT ERE IER'VONE AND@S IT'SE
NVEGHR  OEIESCIT TI@OW N, AN
ER NMIELNG OBEUMRF PEOE
ANI'D VE BNBYOL TD HO TANUSDS
OFEOEPLOW NND AT' IS  CH
NGTEASNIUMND A HINBLG.
COPPELEPEOM UO TE, ME WAN C
N
LY MALKBEAYOR FOU FRR  O
FIESIN MUT EH,AC BUT TYHE
RARER
L
WHEE' WVEEV METE EF BOR
EY MAREGDASHEIR
HETE
AC
ATAKYNL M MEL FEE
ASEON HBLER TRIE LIMATSNSIO A
A@EREA TCH.
OUGHNEARESSEMM IENLY AND
MUSI PASON ANDEL INT ACTLES
ONCAGBRN INO T IT.@
AH, GUESS IEE FLIN KD OF
IS
OLATED.
OUT,BU YNO KW@,LA ISOAYDTE M
IN
ROHE T PN.SSFEIO
IATOLEDS TEN RM TOFHEIA MED
OL
ISED I TMSER OTHF EE TIM@
SE
AERRVS,AL IS CLHE T TM,HE
RSIMTRBU
INOT TD LASOTEHETHWI T
AD
REPUING .BLIC
Y EACLRL AIMEA R
CLYRLRO FETHUS THOFDSAN O
ER AHE TM.LLE AND I C
IT
'SMP ISIOS
ITLDOUN'O DNY ATHG EE.LS@
D ANILD COUTN'T  IENEV TN.HE
AT BUITHNSR S OENE CAN
EARE TH% A ARET VASUM NRBE OF
T HAI WLDOU CLALIT SOLYAR
D
ANUTHEICEE DP RDETH
TE UENIESSTD ATAVHO W H NEOT
NE
GOAYHE T WF  OETH CO
ULTEUNRCRE.
EYD ANTHFRE A OLL AGE ASND A
AL
RLESACND A E ALLNITHCSRO GUP
AS
S IAWGA A LINTASHT NIGND A
VEHENEE WVERER INEE 'VGO.@@@ SHA
D
ANINER CTA D I F'TONEEL
OL A AEDSEREA TCHSEEC BAU,
GHTH
OUIT ADM MS AYANTU SNTDES
MYESLA CSSTHT  ABOALE D■@N.
MYU.Y., AL YEEM SARINRE A@
EP
PRUSTEOSRO LAR.AN
IHAD VEO T MEAKME T AREOUNDS EF
ORTFO TET GO T TKALO TE PPL■@@
I
INLYDUVIALOND A T TET GONO KW
OPPELEIV INDY.UAIDLL
ISOUESY IL FEEAR PYTL
AB TT OUTONUR0  7DAN MBEAY,
E MA
YBBSAMI  OETOLE.
BU TSHAT' JTUSSO PERLNA
UAADINEQCYWH
IATE  HOPRE RTOEPNTSE,T W
T TIRYORE REPNTSE,HAT CTANNO
O
BEE.OLBSET
IFSTHA IOL OBS TETE,NHE W@
O LLWI GWNDO.
BUNG'MEI@OO@ONMO ETI, ALSO
M SOY.
R Y>>OU YIF WEOUTI MENONED
RL
EA SR IEONERAL ONSASCCIO.
WHAT H?
>>EA J
REHE DID MOU YTEEER H?
M>>
I A HETERTAL YE.SH
SWA AATRA GEDE STUNT I
ANERICOL CHIIAONL ORSTY.
AWAI SEALRDY A@TYAC FUL
CTSTINRU.
TINHESHNG ELI DENAREP.
E
'VEE BN@EDAR MRI 42RSEA NO
E OREDRK F MAN MY,Y YEARS
AASOO SCHLOLSY PCHISOGTN  IETHR
PFOANRDLIUBCCHOO STEYSM.@SH
REREE TIDRO FM IT@Y VER
RE
TLCTLUANLAY STE. JUN
I UN'IDTERGER H TO D IT, BUT
WAER VYSH GD  DEIDSEEC BAU I
DRRWOIE AUTBOER HH.EA HLT
'SER VYSFTR SESUL@ JOBEI BNGT
OO SCHL PCHSYOLT,OGIS
ULRTPAICLYAR TAYSEHEUSBES CA
WH
EN CNLDHIREAV HE@INEA LRN
DIICFFUL OTIESRER A LRNIN
SA
DIREDBL O SEE NDCIPEAL
RE IIOATN,SHUT RTHE TIR NT
ANETHOO SCHLSY POGCHOLTIS H
GHEOG TET AWIR TH TCHEAERANETTO
A SNDHEOU WLDOd CE HLE OMALE@
TOFT OEN BNGEI A VY ER
UENSCOEQS YNTEN SHU@ND A
NEN ER PSOESHOU WLDE  COMSTHO
ME
HO TOOSETR SESD.AN
ID OULDE@ESEL HPL TSBEO
NYOF
A TIDOER H
ITIVOLS G MESE MHE MOR
ANCO
MP
CD ANITLDOUN' TO  GONHEOA RD
I@OSEEC BAU I'M TOOUB SJECT TO
EXHSTION, ANDHE S SSTAUSIN
.
ME
>>ID
>>WO TON SS.
>> H O?LD
SNE O I 3
ONE  34.
W>>HAY TDOHE?DO
>> I RATR HENO@
M
IN,EAHE TLD O OERNES NOQU
EITELL.
T W>>HA RBO AUTDIEANG AT,OU Y@
N
OWOR F FKS WCHATIN AND
EYER IENTINTEESD S THIDEAANH
Y' TDHEVEER NEV@D, REAHA WT
CO
REENDAON -RNE- VE AEA RD■@
HO
W YOU WLDOM ROUEC
DYMESOBO?TA SRT>>
ARO  TSTT?
ONES HOP OSECOF UR T,EYT HATH
LL
WI ATA SRTSREHI CLDN.
TFHE TYEN HAV'TTASEDRT A@
CHIFENDR, HEYAV H'TEN RDEAEDL
RDWAEE LR ORTH "EIN WDTH IN E
LL
WIS" IUE GSS ADE WONULRF  @
ACPL
K
TH WNHE IAS W1  1OR 12 AL
AVST H REDEA 100@IM TESIN SCE  H
LEARSKE DIC.NS
ANSEMM IENLY REDAEABL AND
ABLO
VEK. BLEOO@
N, OPE ON,PEUM HOUS,
CHSINGMI, O LEMP TADRE.R
ANF D, O,URCOSEIT WHHE T
RRLEAIELA PYS OF SEAKEHASP,
THWI "MEROOND AIE JUL"T.
TIOU YNO KW, ONE CAN GO ON
TO "."MLHAETAN
DHE "YNR I"V.
D ANMYRE GAT HEROIR SOH JN
LL
AFSTF.
JA@N.US ATE
IMETH SERPL ANLOVS LEIK "NSSEE
D@SE SENY.ILABIT
T O G ON T@O "IDPREND A
ICEJPRUD AE"ND "MAEM" WHIRE A
OFOKBOS OS ALMT SEAKEHASPANRE
QUANITALY DSINT IEN.
AHA WTUT SEDPE?
W UL SSTHOYOU AD?AHO
>>'T DONHI TNK AHE TRE ARENY
ORLERUS EDV AICR OT.HA
ORISATWN O NALURAC PE.I'D HER
MDL HARY ANOC ADVFEAT O SEDPE@@
G.ADREIN
IPEAPNFYS MELO  TBET JUSI AS
GVEHA AATRE MORY, HAD
RT WARULLY WNHE IAS YNGOEER
AALCA SNDATSOU R OEF REA
HITAS FTETUORNA SLY DWELODNOW
AV IAS HETE GOTN O.LDBU
TI IT SD RLLEAER VY QCKUILY IN
BUN AGT AII SUSCTT' IS■@ AN
INHETADE NCAN THA TTS@
THT MGSE BET GENALICLY  IN
TRITTEORNS TRA ITTMIEDN AN
WSO
ME.AYBU
ON IT DNK T'THIT IAT MRsTE
STW HOFAOU YEA RD.
MEOR F R TDIEANGEVREHE NER  WI
E BLLEUGNOHE, TIMND AS A
TY SAINSHIOO BATLT UIMYEL
ADU YOREGA ASTIN C THECKLO
E,CABEUSOU Y KW, I REMEMRBE
ARGIN IN AOO BKDAL CLETH "E GU
STNAN CHAN"NO TIFT DE  WHA
JUNO
T  OSTUR0 7R O5 7@ OR 80
ARYES DNGENEPDIN  UNEDIMECI,
EF
WLAL WEEROI GNG TOIV LE14
O0R50 1RS YEAETH, ERLD WOU
N
BEMEARO GUUT ANTBOHE T
ONCA
NNTH
EEROU WLDENO EHIM TEO  T
ADRETHVE ERYAN
YO IDF H WUO TEA RD ON A
REVEENESTI RAS BISHEATR HA TN
INALECLLTUNDES AETIC  QU
ARTHL REWIT. IAV@ HNOE
BU TIMES L.ITIMEDYO
W, KUNO IHE TRESNLY  MHUC
.TI
ME
E THD ER SOUC MHO TD  REA
THOU WLDEA RHAY LLENENC YROU
A IITS IS ANUERG I TS HIBOOK@
O
ONT LY ONETH OF EOS MT
E TEINNS AOFLL PESASLEUR I B,UTH
K INIT ISHE THEOS MT INALGF
ALL PLSUEARES.
IT NKHI IIS@E MORFO PROTH
TIAPEREUN TCHA@OS MTF OHA WIS
RG UEDN U USS A@PYHE TRA.
ONDOESOT NUA QELRR,
CO,SEH WIT APRI-NDESIESVE
SDR
UGR O AHII-NTSCPHREC DR
THSSRE A E.TIENAL
BUTENWH IES COMEO  T
RI
VASOD MESF OKI TAL
THYAP@ ORVE EN OFTUPI SRIAL
Y,ERTHAPLD W IRG UE AP DEECO
FSEUR OIT SOLYARDI REANG OTH
BOOKSHA TT MTRAT MTE
STIN
■W SHOD EAUYO RD?
YATWH'SROU■@ EMEIRNVON
WH
UL SATHO IDTE? B
WVERER YOURE A.HE>>
ERERWHEVANOU Y CEA RD.WH
YHEETR'ROUELO A ONEH WRIT  OT
RSHE.
V'SIT AER GHIDOO TNG@ TOD REA
OUALDTH WHE TERORS YOU TF ELORO
HEOTRS.
HERE WOURE YNDAN C AHE WN
ER
EVANOU Y C.@
E ETODIRS OFHARESPKEEA'S
ATH.OL FIOSHUB PLIER AEDFTIS
ELSHI FWLOOR ACTS ANDNYPA
SMBMEEREM HSMINGND ALON CDE
FIT BY SAYGINEA RDIM HND A  RS
HRE
ADGAIM A.IN
SOINTHG TTHA ALL@@ THE
EATSALICISHO WTNS IIS SH
AND O TNO TBE ROUD EASHLDPECT
TAAPRHS  TKEORT HEA.@
IITSER VYE RARHE TSE DSAYO TWH
C AATRELEALDH HIG CCEPT■
DOL PEDICITIZ DRSECIRTOHA TT
M WLIILNGSI TO TGHHR TOU A
PE
NCORRFMASH OF PEAKESEAR
BEEUSLE WHIHE T Q OLIUATYF  AC
TRSTO,LI QHEUA OTYF
DI
CTOR PLATIARCUFYRL OBR
ISITHIR D ITOECRSS@  AB
LEINOMABSO
'T D IONFTENANO EAG TT
THAUGROH CTRO PTENIO O
AKWHARPEE ADHIC SNSDE ME.H
>>THABO ANG TUTHISIK LE MUW
DOTE LOUISNMUO SIC WLE
YOU RD?EA>>
OT NLE WHI I RD.EA
>>IL SENCETHN E
ANDS HA WT'EHO THTUG
ER
THE?@WH
YLD WOUOUTN' YIS LNO T
MU
SI
L, W>>ELF I I'M@ R DIEANG
PESHESE,HAERUC,TE DAN,@
CK JS ENOREUS ANTER O
CAHY, ITOAN WT  BNGRIHE T
OL
WHEOFE  M TO IT.
NOUYO K IW,T WAn TBEO OT TAL
LO
STND A ABSORD BEIN IT.
WAT IO T T OE AKMERVE,  TH
T GHOU AMEE THSAIIM TE T WAN
TO
NT MAINAIY MCARI CTIL
FA
LTIE
T  WN'DOTTAN DTITRISACSON
IIFOSAN C PBLSIYVO AIDAV HIN
T
DIRACTNSIO.@
THDAHEOTR Y@ ISOEA RD EWHMEER
O
THMEG INIGATELHTEDE. M@@
E
TH SIOGEUGSTNHA TT WO
ERFUIT BOU WLDE@F I WAD H@
S BOE-ANRFO MYRIEN CTUOW N@@
D
ANLYDDSUENE WAD H TTHA
RVSAT GREHN TECALOGOLIC
NCAD
VATHE ENTRIEDK.OO
UYONO KW,OW HRFON WDELYUL WE
DO
ULE LCWEOM PETHNTRIEDOO@ B
U N'DOTE HAV@ TYWOO RRBO AUT
HEH
ET MYOR URHIACNE@S
OPINERATPRG OPLYER NR O
YO HN'DOTEAVO T DNLOAITD .
U E HSTAV TOIC PPITK  U@,POUYO
DOROG E TEDARNGHIT THAIS IT
R
CALOITY  AH  WNGITUYOND
TTINOW DN  AROR CNEH  WIT IT
.
E BRLEATIT@. A MUSVEARLOCE
H DON LG PYOO U TNLAO
AC
T%>>
AM TDOL THERE ODESINTF
YALEHO I ADIPL SEN MDANT  THAMY
Y  VERSTLAAL YELA CSS IN
RG BOD BY SAGLLTI TKIALNG  LA
NY
MAEARS DNOW R THED.OA
'T WIONIR RET
DOTHEYK INTHAN C ORIL WL
KE
MAE ME.ET RIR
OB ISLOUY H MYLTEAHOE GSCO
LYLEMPTEOMT A SNT PEOIND A I
NN
CA M GOTET IELYSF TONTHE
OOASCLSRMY IM,F  MD GOND
NI
CA NO LGEONR TNKHIND A
TITE CARF,LY I'M I NOT  @@R
WI SLLPTOEA TEINCHG LLN  THEI
TER OTHSEWI,ER OTHSEWI I
HULWODO EOP TACTEH UIL I
E.
DI
HA'SIT WT@ DO.
ARYES.
IAND  IHI TNK@OULDO MAD AND
ELSEORHA TNSE ULESSUTIT WHO
IT
.
S T>>HIS TOO BK.
AL'SIT CDLEHO "EATOW  R AND D
OUHAESGUT SN BEEFE PROORSS
RO
AN THA YEROU VMUCH
YNKOU VERY MUCH, BRN.IA@
@@@@
@